Senator Bernie Sanders wants the federal
government to provide a $15-per-hour-job
to every American who wants one. It's
hard to overstate how silly this
proposal is. Taxes could never be raised,
and existing programs could never be cut
enough to finance this policy at the
level required, and the government could
not possibly come up with enough jobs to
satisfy its obligations under this plan.
This cartoonish proposal is predicated
in part on the notion that there are "bad
jobs", jobs that are beneath the dignity
of what a reasonable person should
expect from employment. It's true, of
course, that many jobs are physically
demanding and pay relatively little. But
it's also true that work confers dignity
and is virtuous. Flipping burgers for $10
an hour isn't a bad job. It's an
opportunity to build skills and climb
the employment ladder; it's an
opportunity to provide for yourself and
your family; it's an opportunity to make
a contribution to your community and to
society. All leaders should encourage
work. Leaders shouldn't denigrate – even
unintentionally – the jobs held by
millions of hardworking Americans. That
message is counterproductive. Messages matter.
What do you think about Senator Sanders's proposal for a guaranteed
job for every American? Let us know in
your comments. Also, let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.